like speaking of like giving like five
stars and one stars and stuff like that
have you ever talked about
what like the reviewing mentality is
here in japan
it just tells us everything it's like i
noticed that right away when i moved
here
yeah how like nothing on amazon is above
four stars yeah
it's not just not on amazon like
everything on like google google maps
yeah and stuffing if
like hardly anything is above four stars
yeah
it's it's like most please then it's
only like two reviews right yeah yeah
yeah
and also like they have a so they do use
google reviews
uh mainly for like restaurants and stuff
but there's also a thing called tabalog
that they like a lot of people who think
their food critics
use it's like the yelp of japan
basically
it's insane because it's like these
people review these food restaurants
and like three stars for a restaurant is
considered good yeah
that's like it's done it it's it's
impressive because i remember when i
first moved to japan and
whenever you look up restaurants on
google you'd see like three
3.5 stars maybe the occasional four yeah
and
in england or in america when i see a
three-star restaurant i'm like
yo but something's gone wrong if it's
below a four then i'm just like
something's up yeah yeah
someone found a rat in their food or
something man like i don't know i don't
understand yeah i don't understand what
that is like do the japanese think that
the stars on google reviews like
michelin stars like
because i mean i understand it because
they actually i i respect that they have
a mentality where they literally
actually use
every star in the review system right
because it's like the mao review
right where anything below like i'm i'm
pretty sure like now below seven is [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i'm pretty sure like mao mao users don't
realize that like under five stars
actually exist
yeah um because it's either like seven
if it's good
um six is really bad six is really bad
like five is the most awful animation
ever like a restaurant
i the way i'm imagining it is like what
would i tell the owner if he was right
in front of me now
right like would i genuinely sit there
and be like this is a three-star
experience
because you know what i mean like
because yeah how are you going to do
that to the poor guy you're trying to
run a business right yeah because to me
you know if i go somewhere i really like
the food i have nothing bad about it
how in good faith can i be like yeah you
don't deserve five stars
yeah because there was nothing wrong
with it like this was exactly what i
wanted
i got what i needed yeah it wasn't fine
dining it wasn't crazy but like there
was nothing
oh sorry i was gonna say like that's the
thing i want to ask about these like
super harsh japanese reviews right it's
like
what is a five star yeah yeah it's like
what do you want to blow drop from the
share cause there's like this is also
another thing where like
you you how can you judge really a
restaurant the same way
mcdonald's yeah because like because
what i was gonna say is
even like the fine dining restaurants
are the same story
yeah yeah that's because they expect a
fine dining experience
so if they get the fine dining
experience that's
that's that's standard that's standard
you've done the job and so that makes me
wonder
what the [ __ ] would a fine dining
restaurant have to do to get a four or
five star man
it blows my mind because like like i
said like comparing mcdonald's like a
fine dining experience
because they really shouldn't be on the
same scale right because
they're totally different things yeah
like so when you go to mcdonald's what
are you judging about mcdonald's are you
judging
the place the food what are you judging
because the food isn't going to change
really
yeah it's probably not going to be any
different the only thing that determines
a good mcdonald's experience
or a bad one is like how fast the food
costs yeah this is what i see on google
reviews i'll see a two star mcdonald's
and i'll see a four star and i'm like
what is the difference
like ultimately i cannot tell the
difference yes it might be dirtier i had
three less fries than i ordered
that's what confuses me because then i'm
then i'm also like okay
so if i rate this mcdonald's a five star
uh what am i rating it a five star on am
i rating it on a five star because
compared to other mcdonald's
compared to a bigger question is
who the [ __ ] is raiding mcdonald's on
google
okay not to be rude but you know people
who are like yes it's my only fine
dining experience
i will review every mcdonald's i go to
people who call mcdonald's a restaurant
the same people call
motels hotels you know i've noticed that
every single
like really really high rated place in
japan
like four or five four point five or
higher yeah there's normally like a
disgusting wait time to get the food
yeah yes because
when you get to that star in japan i
feel like you get like almost like a
fandom like a hype around you yeah a
cult following
yeah so then and then everyone starts
telling everyone it's like yo yo this is
four point five yeah you gotta go there
early you gonna line up and it's like
well [ __ ] now i can't enjoy the place
they're gonna make a
three-day advanced resume i noticed that
as well where there's
japan's restaurant culture especially if
something is like highly acclaimed it
all spreads
via word of mouth where the japanese
love lining up
yeah i don't get that i mean as a
british player
i can appreciate a good queue but
there's as a british person i can
appreciate a good queue as well but not
to a restaurant no you know what i mean
i can't [ __ ] stand cues dude yeah if
i wanna if i want to go to a good
restaurant
that's exclusive please let me book it
please please don't
i don't want another gotcha system i
don't want to line up
i want just to have a booking and a
specific time i turn up
um or you could be like us and try to
book a
table at denny's and completely
fail because we because we always eat
denny's before
we record a podcast and we had like one
of the guests over
and we're like oh [ __ ] that's a lot of
people we might have to book a table at
denny's so yeah we were like
which to to give context it's like
trying to book a table at mcdonald's
yeah
so so maylene called up denny's and was
like uh can we book a table for
six and the guy came back and was like
what is this is a denny's yeah why are
you trying to book a [ __ ] table just
just come to the restaurant please man
this is denny's
wasn't it wasn't it like he called it he
called like the manager or something i
was just like
we don't do reservations yeah making
denny's it's so exclusive
on the day it's it's it's the most
polite way you can just say it's a
[ __ ] denny's why are you calling me
what the [ __ ] wrong with you also even
like going back to like normal reviews
with products like
all the products are like that as well
and like yeah if you see something with
45 stars on amazon with over like 20
reviews you're like
damn this must be like the [ __ ] yeah
because like oh they're paying for those
reviews
yeah yeah that's true because i remember
when i was buying a like going back last
week buying a bed i could not find a bed
over like three stars on amazon no i
couldn't either i remember that
like there was no bed that was about
three stars and i'm like who how many
problems people having with beds and i
would go to the uh
the reviews to read what they were
saying and they were all saying that the
build was too long
and that was the problem that's the
sound that's like your problem i've had
i've had some of the most pedantic
reviews on japanese amazon
i've had like someone one star product
because the packaging was bad
but that's a common problem products
completely fine the packaging was a bit
off so
they were like once that's what drives
me insane is that they almost
always review the [ __ ] around what
you're actually reviewing yeah
like all the delivery man had a bad
attitude
it's [ __ ] like i if the package is a
little beat up but the thing's totally
fine
yeah fantastic are you gonna throw out
the packaging anyway yeah exactly i
don't give a [ __ ] like as long as i can
use the thing
i need so what like this shouldn't be a
blight on the company that sent me it
like
this is [ __ ] absurd